so everyone was talking about I just
thought that we're certainly yeah we're
certainly talking about it this morning
in our earth matters series we're gonna
take a look at toxic algae bloom that
could put the health and economy of
communities along the Gulf Coast at risk
right now all 21 beaches are closed to
swimmers people and pets are warned to
stay out of the water that's not good an
85-degree weather Manuel Bojorquez is on
the coast in Biloxi in Biloxi
Mississippi with more on the story I
guess many the question is how bad is it
well here's the thing you can still
enjoy these sandy beaches but officials
are cautioning against what many people
come here to do and that of course is to
swim in the water they're also urging
people to not eat the local seafood
until the outbreak is all over and all
of this is already starting to have an
impact on the economy here the comb
beaches along the Gulf Coast are
practically empty because of a toxic
algae we're scared actually so we're
staying here in the pool we were handed
here to kind of like stick our toes in
the water but even getting your toes or
his toes in the water it's kind of not
gonna have the problem started up the
Mississippi River where heavy rains
caused flooding to spring officials were
forced to open a spillway to relieve the
pressure on levees the surge of fresh
water which also carried agricultural
runoff like fertilizer from farms causes
the algae to thrive the algae blooms can
trigger health problems like rashes
stomach cramps nausea diarrhea and
vomiting scientists are busy testing
water samples but Allison Robertson of
the dolphin Island sea lab says the
advisory is precautionary as a very very
very low chance of any kind of human
health effects associated with being in
the water some visitors aren't convinced
of the dangers are we going out mouth
deeper chin deep or anything like that
note we're glad
we'll wait in it go around no issues but
many vacationers have canceled their
plans that's not helping business owners
like Barney Foster who was expecting a
busy summer season bought twenty eight
brand new jet skis and the month of July
was supposed to pretty much pay the
notes off and that's not going to happen
now as his rental customers disappear
Foster has decided to sell much of his
new equipment and that's what we're
doing with all these skis were fixing
Halima Georgia and Selam last year
tourism along the coast accounted for
more than two billion dollars and more
than 28,000 jobs I've been in business
38 years I don't think I'll be back next
year I think I'm done officials were
hoping to close that spillway sending
all the water this direction next week
but with that tropical disturbance in
the forecast and more rain likely over
the area here they may have to put that
off and that means there's no telling
how long the algae will last Anthony all
right man anything avoid tough summer
for those Gulf Coast businesses 38 years
and I think I'm done yeah most of the
people sitting on the beach part of the
fun is being able to go in the water
yeah yeah I don't think counts as a trip
to the ocean scientists are wearing
rubber pads yeah it's a clue